over the past few weeks the community
has shown the tough and resilient Heart
of America and that's what it is this is
really America right here we're standing
in America unfortunately as you know in
too many cases your goodness and
perseverance who are met with
indifference and betrayal in some cases
but we're going to find time to come
back if necessary if they don't come
back and give you the treatment that you
need we will be back at the Biden
Administration should ensure that every
family has the option of moving in homes
and everything else until this thing is
straightened out
I mean we have dead fish we have dead
animals we have sick people our very own
Sarah Carter managed to visit East
Palestine before anyone from the White
House she has been on the ground
reporting for weeks from now for this
show and today she did ask local people
what they think about the response from
Joe Biden and his administration here's
what they said
are you frustrated by watching this turn
of events do you think like that this
would actually happen after such a
disastrous train derailment and chemical
spill that you wouldn't hear from the
from the Biden Administration on that I
expected not to hear from them honestly
I'm not surprised they haven't been to
the Border yet so why would they come to
East Palestine you know we're you know
it's pretty much a slap in the face to
go to Ukraine on President's Day and not
come here to the teas Palestine Biden he
ain't coming here he's over there
collecting money off their Ukraine live
from here it's been over two weeks where
is the administration that is in in
power now we'll just say why are they
not here why weren't they here the first
week why weren't they here right after
the mushroom cloud that everybody has
seen and we continue to see played over
and over again as far as president Trump
visiting today how how do you well
obviously is getting a great response
I've seen it up and down the streets how
do you think it's going to make the
people feel though do you think this is
what they need right now yes absolutely
this is what they need it'll lift them
up it's like they know somebody cares
for them when it comes to real solutions
and real problems they're not they're
nowhere to be found and so one of the
things when Trump was in office and like
today he's coming out because he cares
about the communities he understands
what it takes to build a community we
are in a Chernobyl environment here and
the government tells us our water safe
our air is safe and we don't believe
them
all right joining us now with more is
the mayor of East Palestine Ohio Trent
Conway is with us Mr Mayor thank you for
being with us I know I speak for so many
people in the country uh our prayers our
thoughts are with you
um it's it's been shocking to me you
have the president of the United States
uh calling from what he's he's over in
Ukraine he's over in Poland uh didn't
make the time to go visit Palestine
president Trump did today
um you have a really dire situation
there from from everything we've been
able to see and Report dead fish dead
animals sick people where are you now in
terms of getting the help they
originally wouldn't even give you an
emergency declaration
uh so far uh we have I think we have
everything we need
um
but we're definitely going to need you
know more in the future and
we we need to make sure that they uh
stay here
Mr Mayor if I live there and I saw dead
animals and I saw people getting sick
um I would be very hesitant in wanting
to go back to my home do a lot of people
feel that way
I think there's some people that feel
that way a lot of our residents have
moved back in
um and and I'm generally concerned about
their concerns
uh I I just don't know what they they
tell us the water safe uh it's safe to
go back to your home but yet there's
people getting rashes and I mean they're
nervous so it
I I really feel for our residents just
because they're telling you it's safe
like for example for myself I'll speak
only for myself
um I don't think I'll ever listen to
another
anybody in government on any health
issue in the future based on how much
they got wrong with covid-19 I don't
trust them and
I'm wondering
I worry about the residents of your town
and the long-term impact we we cannot
say with any certainty that there won't
be long-term impact can we
no no we can't we can't at all that's
why we need them to stay on the ground
and keep monitoring the situation uh
we're going to need yearly health checks
if not uh you know buy yearly health
checks
um our residents are the you know
they're number one their their safety is
number one Mr Mayor our prayers our
thoughts are with you and your entire
Community we wish you well and we hope
you get all the assistance that is
rightfully due to you and the people in
your town uh mayor thank you for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else